In a previous video, I made a fire piston out of
some scrap acrylic and a lawnmower handle. This
little tool can be used to start a fire by squishing
air, and since it's completely see through, you can
witness the ignition first hand!
Whether you use it as a tool for making a survival
fire, or to explore the science of heating through
adiabatic compression, it's always gratifying to get
a spark and make a flame. I called it a "Slam Rod
Fire Starter" which apparently has been added into
Wikipedia! That kind of blows my mind.
I've had a lot of requests from people who would
like to have one, but don't know where they can find
any acrylic to make it. So in appreciation of
10,000 subscribers, I'm going to give this one away!
Over 10,000 of you have shown your support by
subscribing, sharing my videos, and leaving really
great comments!
For a chance to win, all you have to do is follow
these three simple steps;
First of all, you need to be a Subscriber to my
YouTube channel. There are many ways to subscribe,
but if you're having trouble, check for a link in
the description. Many of you are already
subscribers, and that really means a lot to me, so
thank you!
Next, check out the video on how I made this fire
piston by clicking the link in the description,
And this last part is important. Leave a comment
telling me what size drill bit I used to make the
hole for my tinder claw. The answer is in the
video.  I'll be picking a winner by taking the total
number of comments on this contest page, and using
an online random number generator to pick a number.
There's no limit to how many comments you can leave
so feel free to increase your chances of winning by
leaving more than one.
The winner will be notified, and posted in the
description of this video on October 15th.
Thanks for watching, thanks for your support, and
best of luck!